الحرب الاوكرانيه اسقطت الحذر من العلاقه
الروسيه الايرانيه لا سيما مع بدايه العام
الجديد بحسب فرن بيلسي اكبر دليل على
صداقه المزدهره يتمثل بالمسيرات الايرانيه
التي اسقطت في سماء مدن اوكرانيه عده
والمقدره ب 80 مسيره خلال يومين فقط الحرف
اوكرانيا شكلت ارضيه مشتركه دفعت موسكو
الاحتضان ايران بهدف تامين الامدادات
العسكريه وايجاد شريان الحياه الاقتصادها
وبالتالي التحايل تحايل الجانبين على
العقوبات خبراء اوضح ان روسيا وايران
اقامتها شراكه مصالح ضد القوى الغربيه على
مدى عقود محادثات عاليه مع القليل من
الجوهر لكن الحرب الاوكرانيه غيرت طريقه
نظر روسيا الى علاقاتها مع ايران حتى ان
بقيت هذه الشراكه دون المستوى المطلوب
والقائد صحيفه الامريكيه
الشبكه شامله تزويد الروس بمئات الطائرات
بدون طيار وارسال مدربين عسكريين ايرانيين
الى شبه جزيره القرم لتدريب القوات
المسلحه الروسيه عليها كما ان اللمسات
الاخيره توضع على صفقه لشراء صواريخ
بالستيه ايرانيه في المقابل يمكن لايران
الحصول على تكنولوجيا عسكريه وانظمه اسلحه
متطوره من روسيا
كمقاتلات او نظام سوء 35 الدفاع الجوي
المتقدم مقاس 400 تعاون وضع بيد ايران
كذلك وراء الضغط لتوقيع صفقه الطائرات
مقاتله وصفقات تجاريه مع شركات روسيه
امتنعت حتى الان عن الاستثمار باراضيها
بسبب العقوبات